Michael Shapiro author of the book the
shadow and the Sun what's the main
difference between the image that the
American people have of the Korean
people and the actuality what they're
really like interesting question I think
that Americans by and large have very
little knowledge of Koreans in Korea for
long times existed if it's existed all
the American manager nation at some
place of out there someplace between
Japan and China in that sense the
country really doesn't have much of a
personality at least hasn't really put
the past generation since the end of the
Korean War it's the country that when
which mash was based but which never
sort of really appeared it's the country
more recently if hyundai cars of the
country of the 1988 Olympics and it's
the country of samsung vcr and VCRs and
things like that but the image of korea
is of a hard-working industrious for
seemingly unknown people now there are
cities in the United States primarily
Los Angeles Chicago in New York which
have large centers of Korean Korean
immigrants and in people in those cities
myself included being in New Yorker see
Koreans is very very hardworking very
industrious putting in 67 hour days six
seven-hour weeks 15 15 16 hour days
hard-working but seemingly humorless
seemingly not at all like the Japanese
and Chinese who they've come to know
over the course of several decades and
several generations in the United States
Koreans are different and they can't
quite get a handle on what these people
are about and who they are so I think
this what you're talking about is almost
no knowledge as compared to always
almost scant knowledge in some place
beyond that there is no there is really
an understanding of who the Korean
people are with her about how much time
have you spent there I've spent on and
off let's say over the course of a year
and a half probably about 20 visits I
was based in Tokyo and we commute back
and forth between between Tokyo and
Seoul going spending three weeks or so
in Tokyo and then a month and soul and
it was a back-and-forth sort of thing
and so I've spent the better part of
close to a year in korea on a long year
the year of 1988 which was a seminal
year for korea to the world seoul korea
really for the first time in 19
with the Olympics but it was there was a
lot more going on there a lot more that
revealed itself of that korean was for
me a wonderful education in korea and
koreans what were you doing in tokyo
well i was i was over there because my
wife is susan chair was in New York
Times's Tokyo Tokyo correspondent and so
we were there from 1984 to 1989 and I
had written a book about Japan and when
that was done Korea this was beginning
become big story especially after junior
of 1987 went for about a month the world
got to watch Korea revolt in the street
in the streets in the sense and as soon
as the Japan what book was done I
started working on a book about Korea
and we just shuttle back and forth often
with my wife which made the research
much more much more fun why did you come
back to New York her Simon tendon it's
the there's a length of time in which an
assignment goes on phone we also wanted
to come back to the states it was a
feeling of we've been away for almost
five years and had really felt out of
touch with America in fact I mean one of
the real shots was coming back to
America and discovering things that 1984
didn't exist in the nineteen eighty nine
people were talking about as if it was
the most familiar thing in the world one
statistic that stuck in my mind ever
since I learned it a couple years ago
was that their 330,000 Koreans live in
Los Angeles mm-hmm how come so many what
brought them to this country I think for
a lot of koreans various waves beginning
of the 70s and under the early a tourism
and even now there's a sense of it was a
poor country there was money to be made
in another country and they could
somehow if they could put together
enough money they could move to move to
LA or to New York and to a lesser extent
the Chicago and work very hard and do
well I mean I see it there were about
200 250 thousand Koreans in New York and
honor you see I'm ultimately was seeing
them and you Los Angeles has a
neighborhood called Koreatown I mean
there remains much more established in
Los Angeles than they are new york but
the attraction is it has been for
immigrants for a very long time has been
this is where the opportunity exists the
interesting thing of course is that a 9
20 years ago the per capita GNP for
south korea was $75 and by the time i
left it was three thousand dollars
so it's no longer it's just situation
where there is no hope in Korea and only
hope in America there's perhaps greater
hope in America but careers by no means
a country that is sort of an active
economic backwater or from it have you
ever been in North Korea never been to
North Korea never been able to get into
North Korea where did the Hyundai
automobile come from all of a sudden one
day boom there it was on the highways
and now you see more and more of them I
think the Hyundai will reveal is in a
sense almost a metaphor for where did
Korea come from that for years it would
Koreans are working hard and building
cars and in such industries is
petrochemicals and steel and all of a
sudden one day the world began to notice
that the Koreans were overtaking the
Japanese that they were overtaking the
Americans they were taking a lot of
people know they had the fastest growing
economy in the world and the Hyundai car
was just another part of that it was I
mean this is a classic Korean story
Hyundai is built by a man who was a
refugee after the Korean War who started
a machine shop and began by repairing US
army jeeps and now he is the he is the
chairman now the retired chairman of
this multi-billion dollar industry
sunday which not only makes cars it
makes a lot of things is one of the
seven large conglomerates that dominates
the Korean economy but that is sort of a
classic Korean story of I'm going to
work harder than anybody else and i'm
going to take risks and i'm going to
take chances and i'm going to you know
damn well the obstacles i'm going to
succeed in that is korea what about
samsung very much the same same sort of
thing Hyundai stands apart because it's
um because chungu young the chairman of
hyun day represents so much the
archetypal korean survivor after the
Korean War but you have several
companies like that becomes Samsung you
have daewoo you'll have Hyun David
several large companies which beginning
of the 1960's with the assistance of the
Korean government began to get the kind
of financial support and loans that they
needed in order to build these build
themselves into very very large
conglomerates and very very successful
companies not with the fair not without
a fair amount of risk taking and not
with a lot of other companies failing
and projects that seem like
petrochemicals which seem to have an
immuno a great future and didn't
I mean it's not been only unrestrained
successor has been failure but it's
interesting when you talk to Koreans
about success and failure one of the
people who i ratted back in the book is
one of the one of the five brothers who
is the director of Jindo furs which is
now the world's largest producer of furs
20 years ago these guys are bankrupt
their father had had a bus repair
business that had gone had gone under
and all their friends who had lent them
over the money over the years becoming
calling saying hey up and then and they
were stuck they had no way of raising
money they had no business prospects
sorry they tried first by selling little
paper umbrellas of the climate are using
drinks and Polynesian restaurants that
didn't work and then there was a
miniature duck shoe business that they
were going to try to make it go up and
that didn't work so one of the brothers
got the idea of writing to all the
furriers in Manhattan which is a large
for a district getting the names of the
the US Embassy in Seoul and saying if
you send us your scraps will do
something with them we'll make pom poms
so they got an order for 10,000 pom poms
and jindal furs was born there is a
group of five brothers who were all
refugees in North Korea who came south
during the Korean War who were down on
their luck who were broke and who now
have outlets all over the world who
driven around in Mercedes bother
chauffeurs who have homes in different
countries and but who still feel and
still carry with them what they call
this refugee mentality it's never enough
we still have to show the world we can't
let up and it's such a it's such an
interesting story to hear especially in
the context of success in America
especially in the 80s and going into the
90s now where there's a much more of a
sense of ease about it you work hard and
then there's a sense of you can enjoy
life well the Kim brothers and enjoy
life but there's a sense of yes but it
will come crumbling down tomorrow you
can't let up for a second and it really
is sort of again an archetype old Korean
success story but some basics how many
people live in south korea south korea
has a population of about 40 million
there are 25 million koreans north of
the border and one of the tragedies of
that in which all korean both north and
south perceives the tragedies that you
have since the end of the korean war
1953 10 million families split up 10
million families that have had no phone
contact no letters no nothing there is
in fact it's one of the on the ongoing
issues of tremendous pain for Korean
people and pain and suffering and
bitterness there was a really central
part of Korean life have there been any
Western journalists that have gotten at
a North Korea very few Americans there
was the world it was a sports festival
there in last summer in which a lot of a
lot of Western reporters got in by and
large you'll have reporters from Europe
or Australians will be getting in but
it's very very rare for an American
reporter to get in get into North Korea
again it's this is very very tightly
controlled society in which there's been
almost no information allowed in from
the outside world were all radio
stations are controlled we're hearing
the single voice of the North Korean
leader Kim il-sung and it's it's sort of
an impossible impenetrable place but
then perhaps what we've seen as an
example in the past six months and
possibly in potential places are no
longer so impenetrable how big is the
landmass of South Korea whew um it is a
peninsula in terms of square miles that
I could that is a figure that I I would
I wouldn't even hazard a guess in terms
of square miles it is a country small
certainly smaller than Japan in fact
it's one of the senses if you get about
Korea is that it is a very small country
again I've only seen half of the country
and it's the southern half the peninsula
but you forever reminded about its small
size you're forever reminded of in the
country that is dominated by mountains
very Rocky Mountains and there's a
formidable quality of the mounds of
Korea in which the country feels very
compressed you're also adding to that
have to have the fact that one out of
every four South Koreans lives and soul
a city that is surrounded by mountains
and which you have a feeling of your 10
million people in a basin all scrambling
all trying to get ahead I mean the
feeling of soul is this is con company
of sound of just a million sounds at one
smells sounds screams cry I mean it's
all of it at once but I guess the best
the best image that I would have is that
imagine a city I'm filming in 10 million
people and there's a dime in the middle
of the city and everybody's trying to
pick it up at once that's what it feels
like what's the difference between Seoul
and Tokyo Tokyo is a city of 12 million
people which nothing ever goes wrong in
which it sounds like when you hear
commercials for the new Japanese luxury
cars and they make a point of letting
you know what the sound is like which is
which is to say that there is nothing
but a very very low steady hum that's
for Tokyo feels like I mean I can tell
you that in four and a half years in
Tokyo I saw two minor fender benders and
I and I never saw any violence in the
streets solas nothing like that Seoul's
loud and aggressive and pushy vibrant
and electric and exhausting it's all of
it it is a city that lives in the
streets where the Tokyo is a very very
contained place where life is
predictable the only thing unpredictable
about Japan is the weather and the
weather is not great go back not forever
but go back to Korea long before 1953
when was it a country and it was
combined okay Korea has a has a history
of 5,000 years not all of them happy and
in fact more of an unhappy than happy a
country that has been divided more of
its history than has been a single
unified country the career that we would
think of as the single entity of Korea
if the 30th parallel with the border
30th parallel to disappear really began
existing in the 14 in the 14th century
with the unification of the peninsula
but before that you had warring States 3
warring States at one time two warring
States another time and it was always a
contentious society add to that a
country that because it was between two
strong countries Japan and especially
China was forever being buffeted by
foreign invasions and Koreans will tell
you in the course of the chronology of
their of their long and very often
tortured history that they have had
suffered no less in 976 on invasions
some of them successful some of them not
and so what you've had as a country in
which if geography is Japan's blessing
it being cut off from the rest of the
world has allowed Japan to truly
maintain its homogeneity and also be a
country that was invaded only once in
nineteen conquered only once that was in
1945 and we seen what
conquerer korea has has suffered the
curse of geography a peninsula adjoining
china close enough to japan's that Japan
was able to was able to invade and
ultimately to colonize at a 1910 in
which the Koreans paid tribute to the
unit to the court of China for 250 years
and so it's really a contentious society
that has had to bend before the forces
of great power and that is that history
that capsule eyes history really speaks
volumes about why Korea and why Koreans
are the way they are because if there
was an operative emotion and there's an
operative quality to Korean life it is
bitterness when the Koreans have a word
for this which is Han in fact wouldn't
be interesting things about meeting
Koreans for the first time in saying
what what I'm writing about which is a
lot of what this book is about is Han
you're often asked how do you know that
Han and you'll say well I've heard about
Han or I was told about honor or I read
about on and then they'll say let me
tell you about my heart and Han can be
collective it can be the great sadness
of the past it can be the division of
North Korea it can be anger at the very
repressive regimes that ran south korea
for much of its history it can be
ongoing abuses in human rights by the
government it can be relations between
parents and children I mean it's it's an
ongoing bubbling bitterness which never
really goes away everybody have it
everybody has it to be to be Korean in a
sense is 2 is to 1 it is to feel was Han
the interesting thing is that Koreans
are not only because of their history
are terribly cannot only because of the
history but embellished by the history
are contentious with each other and so
what you get is when you talk to people
who came originally from North Korea and
talk about Han I'm no talking about what
the writer about this and he said well
of course you know we people in the
North never felt that was only people in
the south they're weak we never felt
that way and then he began to tell me
the story about the day that Japanese in
1940 decided that all Koreans who they
have been colonized had to give up the
career names and take japanese names it
can no longer speak Korean but had to
speak Japanese and how they went to the
family tomb and bow before the two
of their ancestors and beg forgiveness
which was that's not hon I don't know
what is and so it's really a sense of
everybody has it everybody would like to
get rid of it everybody knows that they
never really will but everybody's life
is a struggle to try to relieve
themselves of this seemingly
unresolvable sadness there's some square
named Han remember reading some some
theres a river however the river that
runs yeah different hon in fact one of
the one of the problems that I had is
that my level of Koreans is poor to
minimal and one of the problems was that
I would forever be referring to Han and
I would people would look at me and say
hon Oh hon I was never quite got a right
but the honda to our speaking of his is
the river that runs through the center
of soul this is what the book looks like
the shadow in the sun by michael shapiro
will come back to Korea just a moment
where did you grow up I grew up in
Brooklyn New York which is very far very
very far away from from from Seoul South
Korea let me tell you where did you
first where would you go to college I
went to college brooklyn college and
then I I studied journalism in graduate
school of the university of missouri and
i worked in newspapers in New Jersey and
in the Chicago and decided to start
writing for magazines and subsequent
writing books in about eight years ago
and you married the person that writes
the introduction for your book not sure
I did but I married her before she wrote
the introduction to the book it would
always oh yeah we yeah we got married
1984 and moved to Japan a month later
and my wife is was was the Japan hand if
you will and she had studied Japanese
history and jackin she had lived lived
in Japan for a year before going when
she was um had just graduated from
college and so for me asia was all brand
new but what the interesting thing was
that while my wife new japan she knew
very little about korea and one of the
real pleasures of this book was
discovering this country together
country we knew nothing about and I as I
say in the book I mean I'm it's more
with more than a little bit of
embarrassment but here I am writing this
book and admitting that early on I knew
in 1984 even 1985 before I went there
for the first time I didn't know
anything about the country
I had vague memories of some of the
names of the people who you know were in
power it was the president was chun
doo-hwan and I suppose I would have
liked her thought that I had heard of it
might heard of Park Jung hee who had
ruled the country for 18 years because
18 years is long enough so that his name
crops up nothing so it sticks and sticks
in the mind I knew about Korea from Nash
I knew very little about korean exports
because nobody was thinking that I
buying gold star or daewoo a samsung one
day and I was truly embarrassed to know
that to admit to myself that I didn't
remember and I think as a lot of
Americans don't remember that in
nineteen eighty in may of nineteen
eighty korea had its own tenement square
that the government sent in the army to
the southern city of gwangju and killed
between 191 and two thousand people in
the course of the Civil authorizing I
went on for the course of several days
and I'm supposed that I probably had
read about it and I forgot about it
because Korea again was a country that
didn't register in one ear now the other
and only when I got there and began to
see what the country was about and what
the people who were about people who are
at once terribly captivating and
exhausting who are get you caught up in
their lives and then just leave you
drained by the service that they tell
you about their lives people who are who
at times tell you how much they love
America for coming and saving them in
1950 and then screaming your face Yankee
go home I mean it's all of us at the
same time again imagine spending a
weekend with what 40 million relatives
in the summer house and it's raining out
all these feelings come out and at the
end of the weekend what you want to do
is take a vacation all right somebody
tells you that two different scenarios
that tonight you're going to have dinner
with 10 japanese or 10 koreans both from
Asia what's the difference between the
evening well the Japanese evening would
be spent we both first of all both
evenings would be spent if it was a
group of men we spend with a fair amount
of drinking but the Japanese
conversation would be predictable and I
say this in all deference you know the
Japanese who I know and like but we
would regard conversation different
things when the Japanese would we do
Japanese would sit and go so do you like
eating a raw fish you
you eat with chopsticks you like
Japanese sake and the conversation would
proceed in a very predictable nice way
even if we were great friends even if
we'd known each other for years and we
had a truly warm feeling with each other
the kind of conversation that we would
think of in the states is conversation
so what do you really think about this
what's going on at home is everything
okay how's the boss how's your work
going you seem kind of that sort of
thing doesn't really happen because it
would be contentious and people would be
in position of having to perhaps
disagree with each other and nobody
would like it would be do terribly
uncomfortable and so what you have is an
evening of getting drunker and maybe
singing and sort of toasting each other
and smiling and drinking some more and
then helping each other get into cabs
and make sure that everybody got home
okay Korea would be very different Korea
it would be again the drinking because
the drinking the alcohol is the great
lubricant it allows it frees you up to
say what you want to say but I can't
tell you how many times I've heard
stories of watch situations where a
group of Korean have gone after the
evening and first they've they've talked
and they've gotten drunk and they've
argued with each other and you can hear
the voices raised in Korean is it is a
percussive language to put it mildly
made it sounds different than Japanese
which is much easier you can hear
Koreans arguing you can hear them
disagree you can hear them taking issue
with what the other one is say you can
hit them competing with each other for
whose family comes it was better
educated and who makes more money and
who is in the higher station of the
table and who's lower whose kids are
smarter and whose kids didn't marry as
well and then but it would all be very
friendly until and then they would
perhaps slow dance with each other if
there was music playing man men because
there's a lot of physical affection with
Korean then you go to the ballpark and
mental leaning on each other's elbows
and have their arms on each other's
shoulders it's a very emotions and
feelings are expressed very openly and
then they come a point with somebody
would get him to an ordinate with
somebody else and they be a fist fight
very different different from America
too how does the fist fight in this
fight ends when finally somebody the fun
that he breaks up the fight mean I've
heard stories of New York City police
officers telling me the same kind of
thing about going to a Korean social
club at night we're a fist fight began
and they had to break up the fight the
fist fight incidents forgotten people
are still friends the next day
word is it all what's the origin is it
does it all emanate in China and people
come to Korea from China they go to
Japan from China it's interesting
Koreans there's a strain of historians
and Korean call themselves they're out
amateur historians I should explain who
called themselves nationalist historians
who believe that a ruler begins with
them that everything began that
everything that we see is Chinese began
in Korea by and large actually not the
case I mean the case can be made that
would create a lot of things that
civilization began in China and worked
its way to Korea and in turn a lot of
things came from Korea Japan Japanese
pottery began that is all Korean in its
inception Buddhism came to Japan via
Korea Korea was the middle point which
civilization pass him China on to Japan
the interesting thing is that when
things came into Japan and I think this
is a question of culture as well as
geography and a lot of things combined
they went through a process that still
goes on which is sort of a filter like
the Japanese a machine baseball exists
in Japan but it's not American baseball
it's Japanese baseball pottery isn't
exactly the pottery that one would see
in Korea's it's taking on a Japanese
form the Japanese of forever belittle of
assessing of the world's greatest
borrowers and that they're lacking in
originality that's not really get
somewhat disingenuous on their part the
fact is the Japanese take things from
other places and making it their own the
Koreans on the other hand are very
different for instance Confucianism the
zone it was a chapter in the book about
Confucianism the weird fits into the
society because Korea is sort of the
last great bastion of Confucianism what
is it it's a it is a set of beliefs that
confusion is believed is a religion in
which most people would regard as a
philosophy that is really about how
nation states are ruled it's really
positive relationships between weaker
and stronger elder an elder and senior a
series of relationships the interesting
thing is that in Korea Confucianism has
endured near the the rights to Confucius
the right to confuses disciples are
still celebrated in Korea and the
authority by which Korea is forever
being
as it having imposed upon it is always
done of the name of Confucianism who was
confusion Confucius was a Chinese
philosopher who drawing upon ideas I
preceded him preceded him centuries
before his time develop the philosophy
about the relationships between ruler
and ruled the central ideas being that a
ruler is entitled to absolute fidelity
button from his people and obedience by
his people so long as that ruler
maintains a very elusive concept called
the Mandate of Heaven which means that
he is showing to his people at in return
for their obedience he's being kind and
he's being considered and he's being
reciprocal in his he's being reciprocal
in just in extending his kindness to
them the problem with Confucianism of
course is that rulers don't always tend
to be very nice and benevolent people
although they say they are and so what
you have is a series of relationship
that the world has come to known which
seems very rigid and very hard which is
the ruler says or the father or the
older brother or the boss or the anybody
in is in a position of power says you
have to do this you have to obey me
without of course going along with the
second half of what Confucian spoke
about which is you've got to be kind in
response the interesting thing is that
Korea's a country is we're seeing now
since June of 87 the three years since
Koreans Korea's revolution of rising
expectations in which people are on one
hand respectable respectful of authority
and Korean democracy will never be
American democracy the things that make
Korea Korea are different inherently
different than our qualities to make
America America by the same token is a
degree of authoritarianism in that
people will respect their boss to a
certain extent although bitter resentful
of it because the boss will have to show
ultimately that he is at least
displaying some degree of reciprocity of
kindness of goodness let me encapsulate
it all this way in 1987 Chun doo-hwan
the then the then president
much hated much feared by the way had to
get there got there the way Korean
presidents had always gotten there he
shot his way to power it was a military
coup that followed several months after
the assassination of puff chun-hee POC
came to power in a military coup 1960
ruled until his assassination by the
head of the KCIA in 19 in 1979 two
months later Chun seized power in a
military coup aided by the president
present president Noteboom and consult
took off his uniform in that spring and
declared himself president and and tried
to anoint himself with the mantle of
respectability with a mandate of heaven
but he never had it he never managed to
convince people that he was worthy of
their obedience and so what happened was
in June of 87 when Chun went too far and
in the way that he was allowing the
country to perhaps choose his next
president and told them that essentially
they wouldn't be able to be given that
chance there's a country that which is
ninety-nine percent literate in which
the president of the country who would
seize power eight years before tells him
you're not ready to choose your own
president you too immature they rose up
against them and what you would hear
time and again from people was it lost
the Mandate of Heaven not that he really
ever had it but to put it in that
context and I first you I remember
hearing this and saying come on this is
just a little too mysterious surely it
must be something more pragmatic than
that but people said it and people felt
it that he had lost the ability to rule
them hey Dave didn't have to listen to
him anymore they hated him and they were
afraid of him and listen to him and then
he went too far and they stopped
listening to him and that was the end of
it is this the closest today that
they've ever been to democracy they have
had attempts of democracies several
times in the history of South Korea
there was never anything seriously
approaching a democracy and in the
hundreds of years have preceded that you
had a rule by unity was a kingdom that
later became an empire but it was
basically a kingdom right now I can run
by a king a succession of kings some
great many not and interestingly enough
at the turn of the century as the West
began coming to Japan and in coming to
China as well it was a movement within
Korea
korean intellectuals to bring the
japanese in because the Japanese would
somehow be perceived as being a strong
enough force to rest the country free of
the shackles of it's obsolete decayed
kingdom that was the e dynasty that was
still ruling it and have been ruling it
for since the year 1400 in various in
various accession of a succession of
kings the irony of course is that the
Japanese were invited in came in and
ultimately colonized the country what
year they came in in the early to the
early part of the 20th century and an
annex Korean made it a colony 1910 when
did they leave they left when they lost
the war in 1945 in fact me did well the
day in Japan August fifteenth nineteen
forty five which is a day of a very sad
day in Japan is liberation day in Korea
today that they were free for all of
about two weeks until we came along and
not knowing what to do with this country
and not knowing anything about it and
not having really any plan to what to do
with Korea came into the country and
occupied it the Russians were descending
from the north because they had entered
the war against Japan late we had
arrived in the south and very hastily
one night but then lieutenant major in
the Army Intelligence named Dean Rusk
and another officer had to quickly
decide where are we going to divide this
country into an American sector and
Soviet sector and chose a 38th parallel
dean rusk of Secretary of State Fair
indeed how did he get there he was in
the army intelligence and this is an
army decision they had to quickly make a
decision about where we going to divide
this country and they chose the 30th
parallel from that moment on the seeds
for anti-americanism Korea was sown
because even though you can present a
South Koreans especially young students
arguments about Russians were descending
your Kim il-sung was going to take over
the whole country do you want all of the
South Korea to be like North Korea they
still look at that moment of a great
power the United States coming along and
splitting their country and a half as
the great betrayal now in the years that
followed Korea had 12 years of 1948 2
1960 I'm truly corrupt off
rule by syngman rhee who was headquarter
who was the first president of South
Korea an elderly man whose whose rule
ended when he stepped down in 1960 and
there was a brief attempt of democracy
but it didn't hold proxies power after
pasta sauce nation it was another brief
attempt and forming some sort of Korean
democracy in Chun seized power and Chun
was really in charge so now in a sense
we are closer in a sense to a democracy
a Korean democracy and really any other
time his North Korea's closest ally
today the Soviet well not according to
mr. nautical engine North Koreans who
did not who responded I think with a
tremendous degree of alarm to President
notte was meeting with with with
Gorbachev in San Francisco that was a
tremendous blow to the North Koreans the
sense that you get is that the North
Koreans have truly isolated themselves
that they become a difficulty that China
has been trading the South Korea the
years that the Soviets are very very
keen to have South Korean technology and
South Korean investment come to him to
help them try to fix it their their
economy and so the fact that no met with
Gorbachev is a tremendous blow to the
North Koreans and I don't in terms of
great powers and they they're really
very running very low on allies and then
they're feeling true my senses as much
as you can never really know about what
the sense of North Korea is that they're
feeling terribly isolated right now no
this is really off the subject but no
table it I've heard it pronounced
several a note 80 and noting no to how
do you get no out of row it's I think
that his hit the characters are his name
this is the story that I've heard the
character sir his name is no is but oh
but is but I think it's no but I think
what happens that he didn't want to be
perceived as as as mr. know so he sort
of it's somehow became row even though
his name is no I mean it's a sort of a
complicated thing 1988 the NBC coverage
of the Olympics the famous boxing match
what was that all about that was about
and I I don't mean to sound to you know
talk about saying that but but I think
it really was the more I began another
actress Gahan what is it Ernest what
what what the world sewer then was
Ashley a fascinating exercise and it was
not particularly rare for Korea only
rare that the Hollywood it happened on
the one moment when the world came to
watch quickly what happened just that
for those for those who don't remember
that they was a boxing match involving a
South Korean boxer and I believe
Hungarian boxer the judge who is from
New Zealand penalized the South Korean
boxers several times and ultimately he
lost a fight the south at the at the
announcement of the decision with the
North Korea with the south korean
fighter and hungarian fighters signing
on either side of the new zealand
official the surrey korean boxing
officials ran into the ring and started
attacking this judge the korean fighters
sat in his acceptance of the ring and
sat down at his corner and SAT there for
over an hour in protest when there was
this huge fight they know the the the
judge from new zealand had to had to
leave the country for fear of his life
the first day after that brought
pronouncements of shame and
embarrassment how could we have done
this everything was going so well how
could we have embarrassed ourselves in
front of the world this way and then the
next day could change and especially a
change in an outlook toward the foreign
media especially the NBC which had
replayed this amazing scene over and
over again as anybody would've because
it was truly an amazing scene how could
you have how could you have shown the
world our embarrassing ourselves I mean
the logic sounds a little peculiar but
that's really what it was about being as
you was it not shown on a Korean
television it was shown Koreans knew
about it and was shown on Korean TV plus
it was also shown on Armed Forces
television which you can pick up many
parts of Korea so Koreans knew about it
but they were embarrassed about is that
the world knew the outside world saw
Koreans embarrassing themselves an
embarrassing them so embarrassed
themselves they did but the reaction
from what was with the thing that was
telling about it because what they felt
was that NBC the Americans should have
affected them remember hearing from
Koreans afterwards such lines is your
older brother why don't you take care of
us why don't you look out for us a
little bit of course if Americans would
even suggest that they were the old
brother in South Koreans they reach Arab
Lee offended I mean how could you say
there were our our country is 5,000
years old yours is nothing not even it's
250 we can call this year old are older
brother were older than you are the
point is that it really sort of goes to
the heart of the Korean ambivalence
about themselves and about America but
it was really about there is that they
were something happened something went
wrong they were embarrassed and then
they were angry and they were angry
about having been embarrassed and what
they did is they look for a victim they
didn't look inward they didn't say we
are responsible for this we did this
Koreans did this they said you aided and
abetted and it's letting the world see
us make fools of ourselves and it was a
very telling moment because it was a
very painful moment to watch because the
Koreans were so angry at Americans been
NBC officials had to turn around their
badges a fear of getting spat out on the
street is that I had a long well it's
not been that long but a couple you
during these last couple years is that
had a lasting impact on the relationship
I don't know that isn't necessary had a
lasting impact but I think people took
something away from that but it's all a
part of the larger picture it's all part
of those larger feeling of Koreans have
misunderstood and not respected taken
lightly by Americans is there such thing
as Han and China or in Japan I think
that when you talk to Japanese about it
they're aware there's a character for it
but it doesn't exist at all in Japan
it's interesting that when you ask
Japanese businessmen for instance you
know in casual conversation actually I
should explain the Japanese businessman
in front of mine characterizes his
friends as follows cynicism and
resignation life isn't going to be so
great as nothing you can do about it
Korea is about cynicism and resignation
to but in between the resistance life
isn't going to be great and I won't
accept that I won't accept that but I
have to accept it but I'm angry about
having to accept it relate that to the
American cynicism and resignation do we
have any of that where every tomorrow is
going to be better
we have tomorrow is going to be great
tomorrow is going to be wonderful for us
I mean that's how we see the world we
why do we see it differently than they
do because we are a country that is that
is a not that is a society that did not
grow up encumbered by tradition that
held us back you could come here from
somebody from someplace else and you
could start your life anew and the
future held endless possibilities in
this giant country even if you failed in
New York you could go to Chicago if you
failed in chicago you go to phoenix if
you failed in phoenix you can go to el
the point is that it was endless
possibilities it was a country whose it
was founded on the premise of a dream
essentially that everybody can do better
here you can make your life better here
and not uncovered by tradition I mean
you look at things that do that written
in the Federalist Papers about the whole
idea of America of being unencumbered by
the past well of course because society
is 5,000 years old is nothing if not
encumbered by the past and Korea carries
that past with it which makes a country
that in one on one hand lives in the
past it lives in the future but the
presence is a very difficult time did
you spend any time in China no i didn't
have delivered the child take Japan and
Korea relationship between that those
two countries today you have 750,000
Koreans of live in Japan Clarence
citizens can't vote right why are they
there they're there because there
because a generation ago their relatives
were brought over to Japan as slave
laborers to work in to work it for the
Japanese war machine for seven before 45
before 45 will blood over in the 30s in
the early 40s in eight hundred thousand
of them brought over and they stayed on
Japan after the end of the war and they
continue living in pockets of Korean
enclaves most especially in the young in
Osaka woodridge depends second-largest
city but the Japanese have always
discriminated against them they've
always enforce them to be fingerprinted
unless they become Japanese citizens
they force him if you become a Japanese
citizen for a year you have to take a
Japanese name and they did not allow for
a minority with a a separate minority a
separate group that had its own cultural
identification as we would that wasn't
allowed in Japan so there was it was
always a very it remains difficult in
Korea I mean you're sort of on the
outside looking in
are there any Japanese in Korea live
there it's no I mean Korea's is truly a
homogeneous society it's all Koreans
what about democracy the reason I'd ask
you about China looking at that part of
the world you have a democracy in Japan
would you call Japanese democracy one
ruling party that's been in power for
over a generation that has managed to
withstand a political scandal that would
that would have forced out most any
other government you can think of it's
Japanese democracy it's not our
democracy there's so what's the
difference the difference is that people
have lower expectations about what their
government is going to offer them and we
have a lot of ways if somewhat
contentious and certainly at thomson
have a several relationship with our
government and also there are their
mechanisms within the government that
make it contentious the system of checks
and balances we're in Japan it's not
contentious at all it's not adversarial
at all you have an opposition there but
it's an opposition really in name only
you know in any opposition that couldn't
win power after the after the recruit
scandal and after a prime minister had
to resign in the second Prime Minister
had resigned it's really a truly
toothless opposition the thing is that
the Japanese don't see their government
is something that's going that will
somehow provide make life better for
them they don't feel entitled to that
the way that we would they wouldn't vote
out a government that wasn't doing
enough for them longest things are going
okay as long as the economy is moving
all right i'll close their eyes or other
things they'll they'll be upset about it
but they'll sort of look the other way
in korean democracy such as it is and
it's in its embryonic stage right now is
a different thing entirely compare the
three in the united states someone could
truly be born in a small town rise to
being present united states who could
that happen in japan it would be it
would be hard in japan not unlike in
korea door certain parallels here too in
japan he could be innocently born a
small town but he'd better do well in
elementary school now because he'd
better get into a good high school if he
can get into but high school the odds
that he'll get into a better college it
gets into a better college especially if
it gets into tokyo university then he's
in position can really begin to do you
know he can perhaps join the demócrata
bureaucracy which is what separate what
about she she and she there was a lot of
talk last year about tokico
who is the leader of the Japan Socialist
Party perhaps becoming Prime Minister
someday well that wasn't really going to
happen um it was it was a very
interesting story for us to look at him
in the rise of a woman's movement in
Japan but that really was of that
happening with not great I should
explain also that you don't necessarily
have to go to Tokyo University in Japan
in order to be able to come a politician
but you have to do is you have to get
elected you have to become you have to
become an affiliate of the local chapter
of the Liberal Democratic Party the
ruling party in Japan forever and you
have to be taken under the wing of an
elder statesman on the party and money
has to be directed your way because you
are seen favorably by the party and with
money you get reelected time every time
and by moving up within the party
hierarchy one day if you haven't
defended anybody if you're perceived as
you know as a good man then one day
perhaps you could exceed two high
government don't necessarily have to
have gone to Tokyo University but it's
but it's definitely a track you can't
explode out of some play out of nowhere
with the power of television and become
Prime Minister of Japan there's a
communist party in Japan there is your
wife writes an introduction that
communism is not allowed in Korea that's
right it is the years I mean possessing
books that would never would anyway not
even i'm gonna talking to us about about
marks we're talking about something that
was even sort of remotely suggestive of
communism was against the law they were
until 87 they were about hundreds of
banned books i think the number was well
over 600 banned books and possession
that was a criminal offense coming he
was a country after all that was founded
on in audiology when the audiology was
anti-communism as opposed to an ideology
in and of itself the Reverend Sun Myung
Moon came to this country and started a
newspaper in this town called The
Washington Times could I go to Korea and
start the Korean times as a
korean-american friends live in Korea
most most of his adult life says it
really isn't room in Korea within make
making it in Korea essentially for
non-korean and I think that you can do
well as a Japanese working for a
Japanese in a company or an American
doing well working for a company that's
we know that does business with the
Koreans but to make it as we would to
come
to another country and that whole idea
of an immigrant making it in a in a in a
homogeneous society and it's a
completely different place company Korea
is a homogeneous society there's only
room for Koreans we are the great
heterogeneous society of all times and
so there's the opportunity for somebody
like revenue revenue to come here and
start his own newspaper as long as he's
got the money to do it why has he done
it got me there I think that your
connection with the government there
this is somehow it's been intimated
about you know political ties that are
in that sort of thing the thing that I
find interesting about Reverend moon is
that he is he's an evangelical with
himself preacher with himself in the
middle of it and he's met which is not
an uncommon thing in Korea religions
have very important thing in Korea
country with one out of every five
people's a Christian a lot of Catholics
in Korea where you have religion is
perceived as being the thing is going to
save you release you from the burdens of
your present life and certainly of your
past and so it's not on one of the
really telling sites flying into Korea
at night when you're flying over soul is
in the in this great dark expanse you
see a series hundreds of the red
crucifixes neon crucifixes for all the
little churches that have better that
have sprung up all around South Korea
because religion is a terribly important
for trade balance what is it between my
United States and Korea for a long time
is we talk about a country that we used
to we used to subsidize and then Korea
began to run a trade surplus with us and
factory there's been a lot of increasing
less own average certainly in recent
years has been a concreting amount of
tension between the United States in
South Korea because South Korea's
received this protected market and they
were and they were selling it they were
selling very very well to the United
States it's AB somewhat but for years it
was it was a terribly ticklish when I
remember 1988 presidential campaigns
which Gephardt talking about you know
the relative cost of a Korean Carver's
is an American car i mean so i think
it's it's abated somewhat but american
attempts at introducing american
products in South Korea have not it was
not as been retreated populated by
Koreans it was in at em several years
ago for instance to break up
the Korean tobacco monopoly monopoly
three quarters of the population smokes
I mean a non-smoking section on the
Korean airliner means that on one half
of the others smoking on the other half
of the other isn't and it was the idea
to introduce American cigarettes which
had always been very popular in the
black market because Americans you guys
would get them and they would appear in
the back alleys of Seoul markets and
they were very very popular thing to get
especially after the years after the
Korean War it was a sign of the son of
some wealthy able to smoke American
cigarettes now the Korean to back of
monopoly was doing a fabulous job of
poisoning the lungs of young Koreans for
a generation along come the Americans to
say look we want to get into this market
to how can you do this how can you
Americans come and indeed poison alums
of our young people the same logic help
American farmers wanted to import beef
Korea cattle farmers in Korea would come
marching to Seoul and burn American cars
in protest how many American troops
currently in South Korea 42,000 how long
are they going to be there that is a
good question i think that the sense is
that there the number will be decreasing
the students the students who we see
periodically in the spring and certainly
in the fall infinitely Molotov cocktails
offensive riot police believe that once
the American troops leave then the
country be reunified because the
Americans represent the great obstacle
to reunification because that's what the
North Koreans say um I think that there
is one of the one of the tents that I
got even before I left Korea which was
in January of 89 was that the Americans
even if they don't leave are certainly
going to become less visible one of the
really difficult things that Koreans
have to face and Americans have to face
in reaction to that is that the American
army presence is all over the country
but in this myth in the middle of Seoul
there's a young song army base u.s. army
base is in the middle of downtown Seoul
now property values in cell have
skyrocketed in recent years and the US
Army has it has a base with an 18-hole
golf course right in the middle of town
Americans and now I think began to see
that that was no longer viable in fact i
think the golf course is being given
over as a park but for years the Koreans
would see in the middle of their city in
the middle of their cap
in American army base they would go to
one of the big entertainment districts
in Seoul called Itaewon and Saturday
night would there would be American GIs
trying to pick up Korean girls it was
just so many slaps in the face as far as
they were concerned it was somewhat salt
in the wound it was so much anger so
much bitterness it was so much of a
feeling again but you don't take us
seriously you don't respect us the
Olympics was supposed to do that in the
Olympics to a certain extent work into a
certain sense memory the Olympics was
also the fiasco the boxing arena and
then be seeing the economy was supposed
to do that in to a certain extent it has
but Korean still feel underappreciated
they feel resentful of Americans trying
to impose their products upon them it's
all so convoluted and so filled with a
past and with bitterness and with anger
how many Americans lost their lives in
korean war after 2000 but that's about
yeah it was 50,000 the from the UN side
all together i think was about 33,000
american troops that war was from when
to when it began in july of 1950 and
ended in two and a half years later six
months of intense fighting and back and
forth by to be two and then a war that
really began to resemble the First World
War were two years the both both sides
talked north korea and south korea and
men died and civilians died and the end
value to our involvement if you that if
you consider that had the Americans not
not intervened all of South Korea all
the Korean Peninsula would be under the
sway of Kim il-sung and we need only
look at what North Korea's about in that
terribly repressive controlled state to
think that yes I think that wasn't
American there was a tremendous value
did the war have to go on as long as it
did no did we see in all the the
hundreds of meetings at penguin drama
that happened between north and correct
north korea and south korea since a
sense of what was going on of those two
and a half years of negotiations to at
least achieve a ceasefire there's been
no peace treaty and they still
technically at war it's it's a little
bit grating because it didn't have to go
on so long neither north and south and
the UN no they just observe a status
your book and we only have a few moments
left we haven't talked a lot about this
book what when you approached it winter
summer Falls spring what what and divide
it in four sections what's the purpose
the purpose was to give a sense of
following the seasons by showing from a
land that was frozen solid and the court
in the course of the winter which is
really what Korea was like after in
december and january of 1987-88 and as
the year began there's a land began to
thaw as a year began to proceed as the
Olympic scoot closer as the as events
began to take place the pace of life
quickened that the speed at which the
country began to march forward away from
its past toward its past and in a very
very in a in a frenetic kind of way
match the the seasons and went from the
horrible bitter cold of winter to the
just the baking heat of summer and then
return once again to the socom but all
we're the harbinger of winter was there
the point is that I thought 19 the steak
that I made is an American is that I
looked at 1988 and I looked initially
the Olympics and I said AHA there's a
resolution there is a neat resolution
this country that's had is history of
bitterness both recent and long and the
Olympics will come along and the world
will look at it and everybody will be
happy and they won't be bitter anymore
and that was it that was a foolish
assumption and only when I was began to
spend more and more time in Korea that I
realized that the Olympics ultimately
wouldn't matter the same way that
nothing was really going to matter
because the weight of the past is the
weight of the past and you carry that
with you and it doesn't mean that life
is miserable it just means that it's not
always happy every day talked about hon
but we haven't talking to talked about
the other Jeong Jeong law there at the
other side of it yes well it's it's not
so much the other side of it it's the
great leavener it's the thing that makes
Korea a society that is not not a little
static I mean if you just had hun by
itself you would have this great
brooding angry society but what Jung is
is a friendship that we would regard as
and as almost like a straitjacket a
friendship of bonds that last 50 years
of tremendous entanglements and the
Koreans have a word for Han I mean it
it's sticky they're joined together at
the hip and so what you have is despite
all the obstacles and despite the anger
and despite the bitterness despite the
past you have the sense that they're all
in this together that they are joined
one of the the most telling things about
is comes at the end of the book when I
was talking to a dissident very famous
dissident korean kim Conte who had just
gotten out of prison he's back in prison
now but at the time we talked about Han
and I said you know I had always heard
that I'm a Korean funded he thought that
Park chung-hee this man who ran Korea
for 18 years his han was here he was a
small man small stature as the president
of a small country and he said well of
course Park Jung he had hon and then he
talked about the man under whose rule he
was thrown in jail and tortured chun
doo-hwan he said and so does chun
doo-hwan I he understood him they were
in a sense brothers even though their
enemies even though they were on
opposite sides of everything even though
Chun had tons government had thrown him
in prison and tortured him in the most
cruel way possible they still he still
understood him 15 seconds where will
Korea be in 10 years your opinion
hard-working industrious richer than it
is now and so I would I would I would
guess trying to throw off the shackles
of the past this is what the book looks
like called the shadow in the Sun our
guest Michael Shapiro thank you for
joining thank you